surprise
john cena is a married man feels great
that's right e.t can confirm the pro
wrestler turned actor
quietly tied the knot with shea char
zade in tampa florida
it truly is a major thing i'm very happy
the couple filed for a marriage
certificate in early october in florida
and married in a small ceremony on
monday
the two were first romantically linked
in march when they were seen holding
hands in vancouver
where jon filmed his movie playing with
fire this marks the 43 year old's first
high-profile relationship
since his relationship with fellow pro
wrestler nikki bella
the two got engaged in 2017 after john
popped the question
in front of thousands of fans at
wrestlemania 33.
engage life is going amazing wedding
planning not
so much but it's kind of i mean we have
wedding planners and that's as far as
start is a start nonetheless
john what was that moment that you
realized that you wanted nikki to be
your wife
honestly it was a long time ago i knew i
found the right gal and i
i didn't want to live without her but in
2018
the two called it quits i'm like what
nikki has also moved on and in july she
welcomed a baby boy
mateo with beyonce artem chigvincev
i was picking that baby up and
putting it on me and that baby leeched
like
halfway open his eyes and it just made
me like oh my god this is
this is the most incredible thing this
is like the miracle
that people talk about you know so
um just that whole experience like i
want to relieve every single day
honestly shortly after their split john
played coy about his dating life to e.t
are you dating now that's information
for me okay that's a good question i
appreciate you
probably worried about me like what is
he doing in the spare time i think a lot
of people
out there aren't going to keep him busy
man i'm keeping busy that information
i'm going to keep with me
but in october 2019 john gushed about
having shea by his side at the premiere
of playing with fire
i'm smiling because i'm just so happy
for you you look very happy
well it's a wonderful day for a movie
premiere and i got a beautiful day yeah
this is your first time
on the red carpet together yes okay so
you know i have to ask you how did you
meet
uh this movie yeah so he's been filming
this year yeah so that's what's really
special about this one and it'll all
like no matter what
projects i'm involved in in the future
this will always have special meaning
because
i got to film a special project and meet
[Music]
someone